THE IDEA OF EATING
TWICE THE NUMBER OF PANCAKES
THAT LAID ME
SO LOW LAST TIME
SHOULD HAVE FILLED ME
WITH A SENSE OF DREAD OR FEAR,
BUT I FELT NOTHING.
I GREETED THE PROSPECT
OF ALL THIS PAN-FRIED DOUGH
WITH ONLY A VAST,
EMPTY NUMBNESS.
- HEY, IT'S MR. PANCAKES!
- BRING ME TEN TALL STACKS
OF PANCAKES.
- WHAT?
YOU GOT TO BE KIDDING ME.
OH, MY GOD.
HEY, FILIPE, GUESS WHAT!
[chuckling]
[foreboding music]
♪
- AND THEN, FROM SOMEWHERE DEEP
AND PREVIOUSLY UNKNOWN,
THERE SPRANG A RESERVE
OF FORTITUDE AND COURAGE.
[dramatic music]
♪
OR WAS IT RESIGNATION...
OR FATALISM...
OR NIHILISM?
♪
OR PERHAPS
I SIMPLY UNDERSTOOD,
FROM THE DARKEST CORNER
OF MY SOUL,
THAT THESE PANCAKES
COULDN'T KILL ME
BECAUSE I WAS ALREADY DEAD.
- THAT'S MY BOY.
ALL RIGHT.
- [vomiting]
[spits]
UGH.
UGH. MM.